18th century. Under the influence of the philosophers, opinions are stirred.
It's not quite as late as I thought it was.
Royalty, religion, hierarchy, tradition, the very foundations of society are put to the question.
The mind no longer wants to accept anything that hasn't the good as its basis.
If we were to judge a servant by his virtues, there would be few masters who would be good that way.
For Montesquieu, Providence no longer held any importance in the evolution of society.
Like Locke, the English philosopher, he recommended the division of power.
Diderot extols the virtues of science over those of metaphysics and religion.
Buffon tops that one by insisting that the creation of the world happened more than 6,000 years ago.
This is a barbaric...
Always insulting our poor century.
Ah, what might we praise it for? Stupidities of all kinds.
The liberty of thought, universal attraction, electricity, the encyclopedia, etc.
There is violent reaction.
Attacked by the church, Buffon reacts and then carries on more determined than ever.
The first volume of Diderot's encyclopedia is published, then panned.
In spite of that, Rousseau's social contract becomes the Bible of the revolutionaries.
That's our man. Let's hide ourselves until he goes away.
And Voltaire, a fierce enemy of injustice, will always be in the front line of the fight against all that is arbitrary, against obscuritism, fanaticism.
Reason is our best friend.
I'm never wrong.
Four, five, six, seven, eight, eleven.
Poor take.
Ah, shall we go?
Oh, it doesn't look very funny, so let's go to the cafe.
A gentleman will philosophize.
To philosophize is to give to reason all its dignity and its rightful place.
It's to shake off the yoke of opinion and authority.
That's what was written at the beginning of the 18th century,
The Age of Woman, by Madame Lambert,
the gentle and strong Marie-Thérèse's Empress of Austria,
great Catherine is Tsarina of Russia,
Madame du Défant held her salon,
Madame du Barry has taken over from Madame Pompadour,
who reigned over France for 20 years.
As for the king, he might have had the best intentions for his subjects,
but he didn't know how to bring this about.
in the rod that you are holding, and you shall, messieurs, be flowing with electricity
as soon as I pinch the couple wire.
What's that?
Abbot Noli.
And what's the use of that? I'd like to know.
What's it all for? Can anyone say?
Electricity. I'm wondering what it's good for.
All he's done to stop. It can be quite correctly called useless. All part useless.
Tonight was a disaster. The takers only three coins, and so here's one for you, maestro,
one for you, and one for you, Pierrot.
I offer my pay to Pierrette.
And I do, too.
I won't do.
No, I don't want to accept it.
I mean, that's better.
Well, all right, so that you're all happy, you share yours with him, and Pierre share with me.
Uh, why not the contrary, huh? Why not have Pierrette share with me?
And there, that makes two.
I think that's enough for now. We're going touring.
The foreign courts are looking for French actors. I'd like to play in Potsdam.
Oh, and me in Vienna before the Empress Maria Theresa.
And me before Catherine of Russia.
My dear Pierre, you are delightful.
No, no, no, no, no.
Risking to be skewered by the Russian bayonets, my friends?
To be stabbed by the savage Cossacks?
Thank you very much.
Then we'll vote with a show of hands.
Those who are for it, raise your right hand.
It's decided. We leave tomorrow.
What else? In 1768, Corsica is acquired, and just in time,
so that one year later, when Napoleon is born, he's born a Frenchman.
I almost forgot my books.
In 1771, Cugno invents the trolley, and the latest volume of Diderot's Encyclopedia is published,
is published and comes out stirring up enthusiasm and excitement that you didn't want to listen to
me that's the list of accomplishments to date for the century but it's also an indictment against the
absolute monarchy and the church 1775 frederick ii reigns in prussia he is cultivated author of
works in french and sees himself as an enlightened protector of the arts and letters john sebastian
bach came to his court and voltaire stayed three years this didn't stop him from being despotic
anti-liberal and convinced of the merits of an organized army he wasted no time as soon as if
he's in power to use his powerful army to pounce on the austrian salesia sergeant recruits now
what are they up to we have to leave as to you help thank you uh would you mind giving me your
signature why not why not you sign right here sure i uh perfect and you here do i sign there
What's going on? We're waiting for you.
These two men just enlisted in the army.
Don't argue, please. They're all mine.
You're joking, of course.
And if you wanted to, you could be my queen.
You have to help me. Our friends are in trouble.
I don't need more troubles. I got my own.
They were conscripted under false pretenses.
Take it easy all the same.
Hi there. Thank you.
You both signed up. You're soldiers now and you have to stay.
Frederick felt he was beyond the soft, limp sentiments displayed by the French in the Treaty of Aix-la-Chapelle,
even though he was the main beneficiary.
He's a wee bit impulsive, as you can see.
So long, see you soon.
This poor animal won't go much further.
We'll soon need another good horse.
Loaded like we are, one horse will never get us there.
There's a farmhouse there.
Hello.
Hello, good man.
You're a doctor?
oh you're just in time sir it's beyond me my parents are all sick since the king
first ordered us to plant all those potatoes oh we did as we were told and
we've eaten all the leaves as soon as they appeared what you've eaten the
leaves but it is the bulbs that you should eat it's the roots we'll show you
how it's done add a little butter and they're excellent ah now you're all cured
you see how good potatoes can be but eat the roots not the leaves will this
horse do in payment? Oh, that's more than enough. The soldiers, the soldiers, let's go. They're
close. Man, search this farm. Plant these potatoes and then you eat them just as soon as they show
and that's an order. In 1772, Frederick was to be the instigator of the infamous partition along
with Mary Therese and Catherine of Russia. His friend Voltaire voices no protest at all. Hadn't
the king paid for these noble sentiments? Philosophers reveal what should be and the
Kings are there to see that it's done.
What'll we do?
I think we're caught.
Men, seize these fugitives.
But lads thought you could get away, huh?
All these foreigners.
They're Frenchmen.
I'd like to know why you came to our country.
To put on play, sire.
Very well.
You're invited to put on your show in my palace.
But, uh...
Oh, bravo, bravo, bravo, bravo, bravo.
Sire, these men are deserters.
Still gestanden.
Wir machen sie da.
Hun pack schweingesint.
They're coming to Potsdam.
and you had better obey all my orders gentlemen liberalism was used only abroad at home frederick
thought only of tightening his disunified state my friends we have at last a great setting for our
productions that time on the prussia of frederick the great was to be reckoned with it was in 1762
that catherine came to the throne of russia well almost but there was her husband the weak peter
the third who no sooner in power sided with frederick of prussia to whom he gave his undying
admiration there was a little straightening out to do and it would come soon enough and somewhere
locked in a dark dungeon there was the pretender to the throne ivan the sixth who had reigned only
a few months that problem would be solved soon enough too and catherine empress at 33 would be
able to continue the good work of peter the great modernizing her state pushing back her borders
from the Baltic to the Black Sea.
The great Catherine is also protectors of the arts and letters.
An enlightened despot, she keeps the enlightenment of the age
for her personal use and for propaganda.
She uses her blustery liberalism.
The serfs are bought and sold like cattle.
It's a treatment they give to people who deserve it.
Diderot, in 1773, Catherine says to him,
With your great principles, you're making fine books and very poor men.
But you're cultivating misery for your people.
What about the rights of men?
You, you, sir, work only on paper.
It suffers you, my friend.
Potemkin!
Highness.
That's the beautiful city of St. Petersburg.
It was a Peter, the Great, who constructed it.
This river is the Naver, the principal means of communication along all the big buildings here.
And they're putting in those huge piles and putting them deep to build on marshy land there.
But let's be fair, Doctor.
Whenever youth and love get together to boil an old man,
anything they might try to do might in the end be termed useless.
Dear Potemkin, I would like your opinion in the matter.
Here are the French actors you asked to come to your royal court.
Welcome.
Welcome to you all.
Does this young man also belong to your group?
Yes.
It's just the 938, your majesty.
Actors are to play before the court.
I want to talk to the young man in blue.
That's your wish, Heinels.
Monsieur, her majesty commands your presence at the performance tonight.
Uh, I don't know, I...
Be careful, at the palace one obeys all orders.
Dan, do you want to be Pierre the Fourth, or perhaps Pierre the Great with your Catherine?
We've got a role that suits you.
But do I have any choice?
Excuse me, I'll show you what choice you've got.
Ah, me no. Our actors will not play before the court.
Come on, Pierrette, you'd best think it through. You'll see. You'll be sorry if you're like this.
I'm sorry, but I'm leaving.
Immense domains belonging to the clergy were secularized.
Entire villages built in the Ukraine on the Volga.
Judicial and executive powers were made separate.
The wealthy landowners were heavily taxed.
In spite of everything, Catherine the Great really deserved her country.
This unified Austrian empire contained 24 million inhabitants.
In 1740, when the Habsburg throne falls to her, Marie-Thérèse is 23.
This awakened the greediness of her neighbors.
Frederick II's brand new army lost no time in seizing Silesia.
France, Spain, Saxony, and Bavaria make an alliance with Prussia.
How time flies! Our little Pierre is two years old today.
But the pious and gentle Marie-Thérèse stands firm.
With the help of her clever minister, Kalwaneets, and her generals, Daun and Lassie, she holds up against the entire house of Austria.
Why are you tricks like a fish?
This one is empty. That's too bad. Not much we can do for you, my good friends.
I'm sure I saw them in before. They might be able to refill our bottle.
There it is.
Good day, gentlemen.
Men, this way in peace.
Looks like we've got some good customers there.
Don't you want to offer them a drink on the house?
A drink?
I know thank you all the same.
I'm not used to being refused.
Oh, no, we're in for it.
Okay, friends.
I command you to seize them.
This time everything seems to have gone well.
Perhaps another problem with recruiters.
Pray no one hurts them.
I almost forgot.
Look what I forgot.
In 1772, the virtuous Marie Therese painfully resigns herself to the infamous partition of Poland.
Poland. And even though she could not oppose her Prussian and Russian neighbors, she at least
managed to get the largest portion, Galicia. Come and see my fresh vegetables. All the good
things to eat fresh vegetables. Come and see. Don't be shy. Oh, I'm thirsty. Can we stop? Oh,
look, there's an inn. Have we got time for a little drink? Don't you agree? That's not a bad
idea. I'll go with you. Oh, no. You know, I think that you've had enough. I'll go and take
a little look it's fine why don't we stop at this place we'll catch the devil we don't find
someone but the feeling will pick up one or two in there you are sure oh welcome don't go away
since the year 1765 joseph the oldest of 16 of the empress's children was heir to the throne
one of his daughters the austrian marie antoinette was to come to a tragic end on the throne of
France.
Schoenbrunn cashless which way?
In front of you, you see.
Just in front of you.
Oh, thank you.
The young Mozart is often a guest of the royal family at the Chateau of Schoenbrunn.
The day is moving much slower than I thought.
As best it could, the patient efforts of Marie-Thérèse continued to be felt until 1918,
and Vienna remained the special center of a brilliant civilization.
Oh, no, Southern Abbot, the air is so high and noble it must be Count Alma-Vito.
I think I think it's that Rascal Figueroa.
In 1783, it is in England that our French actors feel they would like to set up their stage.
Adam's theory, live and let live, is the Bible of the English middle class.
It'll show Europeans to be thinkers and contribute to the blossoming of liberty.
David Hume, a disciple of Locke, goes on about the virtues of experience, which alone can teach.
Experience alone instructs.
It's been well instructed.
Watt keeps on improving his steaming.
He adds the alternating piston to it.
Experience is the only truth.
This time.
Oh my goodness.
Well, well, well.
All right, I'll try something else.
Oh, you'll never grow.
All right, all right, we'll do another one.
Let's see.
Here, Graves, Arkwright, Crompton, improve the spinning machine.
Come and look, it's England.
Cartwright will perfect the mechanized weaver.
I'd say it was perfect.
Don't!
Love to do that, too.
All right.
Let's do it.
Hey, wait for me to get closer, will you?
Hey, yo, please, we don't want you to jump any garbage on our beach.
They were manufacturing cast iron from Coke.
It was the Industrial Revolution.
And any kind of work was productive.
Well, for some, more than for others.
To fight against the miserable condition of the proletariat,
the first trade unions were formed as far back as 1776.
There were the first strikes.
I say my dear, build tobacco.
This same year, 1776, was the year of the Declaration of Independence of the United States of America.
It was also the year of the rejection of equal taxation
by the parliament of Paris.
Oh, they're not going too fast.
Well, you look at the slow folks there.
Bet you I could put the boat in the first place in no time at all.
I'd like to show them.
I'd like to show those guys.
I did it.
To make up for their defeat in the Seven Years War,
France gets involved in the war in America.
Lafayette and Bochambeau will distinguish themselves.
Soccer! Soccer! Not too bad!
As 24, William Pitt Jr. takes over the head of the government
to put the economy back on its feet after the war in America.
And Wesley founds the Methodist Church with no pomp and circumstances.
All together!
5,000 years after the Hindus, 3,000 years after Crete,
After Crete, a Scottish inventor finally finds the way to immortalize his name, a caddam.
It is more than clear that any person who persecutes his fellow man,
because he doesn't share his opinions, is a monster, said Voltaire.
And though Voltaire, Diderot, D'Alembert, and Rousseau no longer lived,
their ideas were more alive than ever.
Supplies that I invented will allow us to achieve in no time.
Hey, hey, hey, you keep on feeding that kid's mind with all kinds of crazy things you're getting on my nerves.
Look at the kid.
Hey, you did that.
Just a minute, hold it. What's all this about? Let's go of me, will you? Let's go, you're crazy.
Why don't you relax a bit, huh?
No, I can't. He's nuts.
The English were defeated in America.
British Versailles in 1783 recognized the independence of the United States.
Just like children. You're just about through, are you?
Down. Put them down.
All right, all right.
German Herschel discovers the planet Uranus.
He studies the ring on Saturn, the Milky Way, and the Swiss Euler creates integral calculus.
Don't nature, nothing is created, nothing lost.
Lavoisier is the founder of modern chemistry and language of analytical mechanics.
One would want to do that.
It's idiotic and it's useless.
Blanchard and Jeffrey succeed in crossing over the English Channel in a balloon.
Oh, come on, let's go get it.
Down with the, down with the invaders.
Wait, don't do that, don't do that.
There's no reason to do that.
Why, he's an evil monster and a contraption, the devil.
No, my good friend, he's just a man.
This contraption is progress.
No witches around here, do you understand?
But he's not a witch.
He's not a witch.
Oh, I don't want to know.
Get on your way.
Come on, let's go.
We still have a chance to leave safely.
Very well, I won't insist, since that's your opinion.
Gentlemen, let's go.
The Age of Enlightenment, says Kant, is when man becomes of age.
Witches.
Go and see if there's room.
Friend.
Motherfucker.
The same year that the American rebels launched their Declaration of Independence,
based on the French philosophy of the Age of Enlightenment,
In 1776, the Parliament of Paris vehemently opposed equal taxation that Turgot was supporting in spite of the opinion of everyone else.
Taxes!
Equality? An unacceptable system which will bring civil disorder claimed the learned assembly.
This society, which refused reform of any kind, was soon to experience utter upheaval.
This general would be summoned to Versailles on the 5th of May, 1789.